[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein 5 Minuten Dessert,
was ihr gerade jetzt zur Ramadan-Zeit
perfekt zubereiten könnt.
Aber auch außerhalb der Ramadan-Zeit
ist es wirklich das perfekte Dessert!
Und zwar heißt es Katmer Tatlısı.
Katmer, das sind im Prinzip so einzelne Schichten
wie so eine Art Blätterteig.
Aber in der Türkei wird nicht Blätterteig gemacht,
sondern einfach Yufka verwendet.
Entweder ein Baklava-Yufka,
also so ein ganz dünner Strudelteig.
Ich nehme jetzt aber gleich Filoteig.
Ihr braucht dafür wirklich nur fünf Zutaten.
Und das ist ein Dessert, was ich auch aus der Türkei kenne.
Man kennt es zum einen aus Gaziantep.
Wir haben es aber auch schon
in Malatya oder in Istanbul gegessen.
Und zwar gibt es da so eine Kette,
die nennt sich Mado und die machen wirklich gute Desserts.
Auch eigentlich ganz gute Hauptspeisen.
Und das ist ein Dessert gefüllt mit Pistazien,
ganz dünn gebacken.
Man könnte auch meinen, es wäre herzhaft,
weil es einfach wie Börek aussieht.
Aber es ist wirklich richtig lecker!
Das Ganze ist auch nicht zu süß,
sodass ihr euch jetzt entscheiden könnt,
ob ihr noch einen Zuckersirup dazu machen wollte oder nicht.
Ich zeige euch jetzt gleich noch,
wie ich den Zuckersirup ansetze.
Ansonsten könnt ihr es aber auch wirklich
komplett ohne servieren.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich auch nur die fünf Zutaten.
Und in fünf Minuten ist es auch schon fertig.
Aber, wie gesagt, mache ich jetzt noch den Zuckersirup
Denn man bekommt es auch dort immer
auf so einem schönen Teller angerichtet
und dann den Zuckersirup in einem kleinen Kännchen
und man kann einfach dann selber dosieren,
wie süß man es haben will.
Für den Zuckersirup nehme ich
50 Gramm Wasser,
100 Gramm Zucker,
ein bisschen Orangenblütenwasser
und etwas Zitronensaft.
Ich gebe jetzt einfach das Wasser in einen Topf,
den Zucker hinterher.
Orangenblütenwasser könnt ihr auch gerne nehmen.
Das macht es einfach etwas orientalisch.
Jetzt verrühre ich das hier kurz
und lasse es dann direkt schon auf dem Herd aufkochen.
Und beim Kochen da achte ich dann darauf,
dass es vom Löffel herunterfließt wie so ein Faden.
Also er darf einfach nicht mehr
zu flüssig sein, aber auch nicht zu dick.
Wir wollen ja keinen Sirup herstellen,
also nicht so einen dicken Sirup herstellen.
Und dann gebe ich einfach noch
einen Spritzer Zitronensaft mit rein,
damit das Ganze nicht kristallisiert.
Und geschmacklich passt es eben auch dazu.
Aber, wie gesagt, müsst ihr das nicht.
Das könnt ihr nur machen.
[Musik]
Ein bisschen muss es noch.
Also man sieht jetzt hier,
dass der Faden immer noch so ein bisschen abreißt.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist es perfekt!
Jetzt fließt es schön geschmeidig.
Und jetzt einfach nur
einen kleinen Spritzer Zitronensaft reingeben
und dann einfach abkühlen lassen.
Für das restliche Dessert braucht ihr
wirklich nur diese fünf Zutaten.
Ich habe jetzt hier Filoteigblätter.
Die bekommt ihr in jedem Supermarkt.
Und die sind einfach richtig schön dünn.
Also Strudelteigblätter.
Dann habe ich hier etwas Crème fraîche.
Normalerweise gehört aber Kaymak rein.
Kaymak ist einfach Rahm, so ein süßer Rahm.
Hier habe ich noch Pistazien,
Puderzucker
und Butter.
Das war es schon.
Die große Menge Butter,
die kann ich jetzt schon mal schmelzen.
Die brauche ich nämlich gleich zum Bestreichen.
Und die kleine Menge Butter gebe ich jetzt auch
direkt schon in eine große Pfanne.
Die kann ich hier auch schon mal schmelzen.
[Musik]
Dann geht es los.
Dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt einfach
zwei Filoblätter übereinander.
[Musik]
Und immer dann schnell arbeiten,
damit die einfach nicht austrocknen.
Ich sehe hier schon, das erste ist so ein bisschen trocken.
Das benutze ich dann für was anderes.
[Musik]
Und dann schön mit der Butter bestreichen.
Als Nächstes den Rahm nehmen.
[Musik]
Mit Kaymak wäre es halt wirklich original türkisch.
Den Rahm verteile ich jetzt mehr hier so in der Mitte.
Oh!
Die Pistazien muss ich noch zerkleinern,
kurz zermahlen.
[Musik]
Ich mahle sie jetzt so, dass ein paar schön fein sind
und andere so ein bisschen grob.
Und, da ich jetzt vier Portionen mache,
einfach immer alles schön
im
Auge...
Wie heißt das? Im
>> AYLIN: Geistigen Auge.
>> SALLY: geistigen Auge.
Im geistigen Auge vierteln.
Also so könnt ihr euch das dann immer schön aufteilen
von der Portion her.
Bei mir sind es jetzt auch vier.
Also nehme ich jetzt hier ein Viertel.
Dann noch den Puderzucker drüber.
Und statt Pistazien könnt ihr
zum Beispiel auch Mandeln nehmen
oder Walnüsse,
Haselnüsse.
Das bleibt euch überlassen.
Okay.
Und jetzt einfach schön zusammenklappen.
Ich klappe jetzt hier die eine Seite ein
wie so eine kleine Tasche.
Dann die andere.
Und einmal von oben nach unten.
[Musik]
Und von unten nach oben.
Und dann habt ihr ein kleines Päckchen.
So bereite ich jetzt kurz alle vor.
Und dann werden sie schon ausgebacken.
Wie versprochen,
fünf Zutaten,
fünf Minuten.
So.
Jetzt ist hier die Butter schon schön geschmolzen.
Und ich kann im Prinzip schon alles ausbacken.
Also von beiden Seiten
einfach, bis es schön goldbraun ist.
Und dann wird das Dessert gleich warm serviert.
Entweder zu einer Kugel Eis
– Joghurteis passt perfekt –
oder zu einer Kugel
– Kugel sage ich schon –
zu einem Löffel kaltem Sahnejoghurt,
also richtig stichfest.
Und dazu dann noch ein paar
gehackte Pistazien.
Noch der Zuckersirup.
Perfekt!
Mehr braucht man nicht.
[Musik]
Jetzt warten, bis die Pfanne heißer ist.
Ich habe sie gerade runtergestellt,
damit die Butter nicht verbrennt.
Butter bei Stufe 1
und die jetzt bei
– okay, ich habe jetzt auch
den Pfannensensor drin – bei Stufe 4.
Aber ansonsten bei mittelhoher Hitze einfach
schön ausbacken von beiden Seiten.
[Musik]
Hole ich denn den Murat zum Probieren?
Mh.
Ich richte schon mal meine Teller
und
den Joghurt.
Und den Zuckersirup
habe ich übrigens schon umgefüllt in kleine Kännchen.
Also das ist jetzt eine große Kanne,
so eine Mokkakanne.
Aber hier,
so bekommt man es in der Türkei dann auch serviert.
Also richtig schön.
Und dann kann man sich eben auch die Süße dosieren.
Also manche nehmen dann das ganze Kännchen,
andere nur ein bisschen.
Kann man dann selber variieren.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt habe ich alle fertig angebraten.
Ich rufe mal Murat zum Essen.
Murat!
Murat, Essen ist fertig!
Einmal in die Küche bitte!
[Musik]
Schnell!
So.
Zum Servieren
schneide ich jetzt zuerst einmal Dreiecke.
>> MURAT: O Mann, he!
Wahnsinn!
Das hat meine Mama immer gemacht.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Ja. Voll.
Und zwar
hat meine Mama dafür einen Saç, nennt sich das.
Ich weiß nicht.
>> SALLY: Oh, ja!
>> MURAT: Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr in der Türkei in Urlaub seid
und da sind dann diese Frauen,
die dann an so einem riesengroßen...
Wie sagt man da?
Wie sagt man dazu?
>> SALLY: An so einem
>> MURAT: Wie so eine Riesenpfanne. Saç.
>> SALLY: Ofen. Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, so ein Ofen.
>> SALLY: So ein Blech.
>> MURAT: Und das dann machen.
Das ist so lecker!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Woah, ich liebe das echt!
Und das kann man auch mit Kartoffeln machen.
>> SALLY: Äh.
>> MURAT: Nicht?
>> SALLY: Du bist gerade falsch. Das ist was Süßes.
>> MURAT: Ach, das ist was Süßes?
>> SALLY: Und das haben wir bei Mado gegessen.
>> MURAT: Oh. Ich habe gedacht, ich kriege was Herzhaftes.
>> SALLY: Nö, das ist jetzt was Süßes.
>> MURAT: Okay. Dann mache ich es noch mal.
Ach, das ist ja der Wahnsinn!
Das habe ich damals
in der Türkei bei Mado gegessen!
Mado hört sich an wie Made,
aber Mado ist
ein bekanntes Restaurant in der Türkei.
Das ist so eine Kette.
Und die machen halt richtig tolle Sachen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist es richtig.
>> MURAT: Habe ich richtig.
>> SALLY: Und
ich habe es jetzt hier.
Guck mal. Ich mache das so.
>> MURAT: Ich habe meine Mutter gerade vermisst.
Weißt du das?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich auch.
>> MURAT: Die hat das auf dem Saç gemacht
mit den Kartoffeln.
>> SALLY: Oh! Und Maisbrot und so.
>> MURAT: Und Maisbrot.
Hey, meine Mutter ist so toll! Ehrlich!
Die macht so coole Sachen.
>> SALLY: Irgendwann kommt sie wieder.
>> MURAT: Aber du bist auch nicht schlecht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Du bist auch gut!
So.
Dann probiere ich das aus.
>> SALLY: Also
bei Mado haben wir es einmal mit Eis gegessen
und einmal mit Joghurt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde es tatsächlich mit Joghurt besser.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Stichfesten Joghurt nehmen.
>> MURAT: Das hört sich jetzt für euch vielleicht komisch an,
Joghurt mit etwas Süßem.
Obwohl, das gibt es schon öfters, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja, Fruchtjoghurt.
>> MURAT: Fruchtjoghurt. Stimmt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube eher, dass im Deutschen
Joghurt mit etwas Herzhaftem komisch ist.
Weil
>> MURAT: Ja, stimmt. Ja.
>> SALLY: wir in der Türkei essen alles mit Joghurt und
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: in Deutschland kenne ich Joghurt nur bei Müsli,
>> SALLY: als Dessert.
Aber herzhaft nie, nicht?
>> MURAT: Die nehmen sogar...
Wenn die Tür quietscht, nehmen sie auch Joghurt,
um das wieder wegzubekommen.
Das ist normal in der Türkei.
>> SALLY: Also
>> MURAT: So.
ich finde, so in Deutschland ist Joghurt...
>> JOSH: Zu Kartoffeln, oder? Zu so...
>> SALLY: Zu Kartoffeln Quark eher, nicht? So.
Oder ja, Joghurt.
Ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, zu was ihr
gerne Joghurt serviert.
Also hier noch ein paar Pistazien.
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt noch nicht so süß.
Aber
jetzt nehmt ihr das
und dieses Kännchen
und gießt das jetzt hier schön drüber.
[Musik]
Also ich will ja nicht sagen,
aber, wem jetzt das Wasser nicht im Mund zusammenläuft,
weiß ich auch nicht.
>> MURAT: Du musst noch...
>> SALLY: Hier ist noch ein Messer.
>> MURAT: Kannst du mir trotzdem mal einen Gefallen tun?
Ich meine,
>> SALLY: Ja?
ich bin mir 100 Prozent sicher,
das schmeckt jetzt wirklich super.
Aber könntest du das auch mal
mit Spinat und Hackfleisch machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, herzhaft.
>> MURAT: Bitte. Ohne Spaß.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Hey, herzhaft ist so genial!
Darf ich?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Boah, das ist Hammer!
He!
Ich weiß, es läuft gerade euch
wahrscheinlich...
Vielleicht tun manche von euch jetzt gerade fasten.
>> SALLY: Dann probiert es auf jeden Fall aus!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Holt schon mal alle Zutaten.
>> SALLY: Und das ist halt jetzt perfekt,
die Kombi.
Denn der Joghurt ist nicht gesüßt.
Das heißt, einfach nur stichfester, kalter Naturjoghurt,
Sahnejoghurt.
Hier die leichte Süße.
Warm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Der Hammer ist, weil es nicht zu arg süß ist.
Das ist bei orientalischen Speisen oftmals so,
weil sie so oft Zucker benutzen.
Aber das ist so genial!
Diese Kombi.
>> SALLY: Ich will jetzt auch probieren.
Mmh!
>> MURAT: Josh. Hammer!
>> SALLY: Und dann
das Orangenblütenwasser
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: im Sirup, nicht?
>> SALLY: Mega!
>> MURAT: Wenn ihr es natürlich jetzt voll übertreiben wollt,
könnt ihr Folgendes machen.
Anstatt dem Joghurt könnt ihr auch Vanilleeis dazu nehmen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Dann habt ihr es aber übertrieben.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Nicht? Was?
>> SALLY: Zitroneneis!
>> MURAT: Zitroneneis?
Aber dann haben sie es übertrieben, oder?
>> SALLY: Oder Joghurteis.
>> MURAT: Ja. Übertreibt nicht eure Rolle.
Nehmt Joghurt dazu. Wirklich.
Ist Hammer!
>> SALLY: Frozen Yogurt ist auch genial!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
Und man kriegt die Portionen,
finde ich, schon gut alleine
leer,
weil es eben nicht so süß ist.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Oder ihr sagt, ihr teilt es.
Dann sind es
acht etwas kleinere.
>> MURAT: Das teilt keiner!
Glaub mir. Das teilt keiner.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß. Aber, wenn man vielleicht am Abend
nicht so viel essen will, eher langsam.
Wir machen jetzt die Kamera aus.
Denn ich glaube, der Josh will unbedingt probieren.
Das Rezept gibt es zum Nachlesen
natürlich kostenlos in meiner App,
in der Sallys Welt App.
Die könnt ihr überall kostenlos herunterladen
für im Google Store oder auch
Apple.
Und probiert es einfach aus!
Fünf Minuten, fünf Zutaten
und perfekt!
>> MURAT: Wisst ihr was?
Teilt es nicht! Seid mal selbstsüchtig!
Ohne Spaß.
Seid einfach mal selbstsüchtig,
weil es einfach geschmeckt hat.
Ihr müsst nicht immer alles teilen!
>> SALLY: Weißt du was?
Im Winter stelle ich mir das noch vor
mit Haselnüssen, Zimt, Tonka.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: So richtig so, so winterlich.
>> MURAT: Rede du weiter. Solange du weiterredest,
kann ich nämlich alles essen.
Ist okay. Erzähl deine Geschichten.
>> SALLY: Och, ich bereite gleich noch die nächsten zu
Und dann
essen wir das jetzt alle.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Ein Gruß an meine liebe Mama!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oh, Mama, deine Börek-Brötchen!
Die sind der Hammer! Ehrlich!
Ich habe die so vermisst!
>> SALLY: Türkçe konuş Annen Almanca bilmiyor.
>> MURAT: Ya Anne.
>> SALLY: Seni çok özledim.
>> MURAT: Seni çok özledim.
Herşeyini bütün yemeklerin de özledim.
Bütün börekleri özledim.
Hele şu patates böreği ve ıspanak böreği çok özledim.
Almanya'dan selamlar!
>> SALLY: Mısır ekmeği?
Mısır ekmeği!
Hamsi Anne
>> SALLY: Hamsi tavası!
>> MURAT: Hamsi çok özledim.
Seni çok özledim.
Hamis çok özledim.
Macht es gut!
Tschüss, Mama!
Ellerinden öperim.
Mmh!
Annem gibi yok!
Ja.
Annem gibi yemek yapamıyor!
Ehrlich! Muss ich einfach sagen.
Tut mir leid.
Annem seni özledim!
>> SALLY: Du Schleimer!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mama kocht am besten!
[Musik]